hätten sie sich das träumen lassen dass
deutschland in dieser krise so nach
hinten rutscht im vergleich zu anderen
ländern also ich denke es passt nicht zu
uns wir sind ein technologiestandort
hochtechnologiestandort ja das hat uns
groß gemacht und das ist auch eine
stärke von uns und ich glaube wir müssen
uns dieser stärken wieder vergewissern
und auch so zusammen mit blick nach
vorne
sagen wir packen das wir gehen das an
zusammen und wir mobilisieren die
kräftig denke dass wir stärker machen
können ist dass wir das ganze hinter ein
ziel bild setzen und etwas vorherzusagen
der sommer wir sehen den sommer wir
haben ja auch eine perspektive das
sollten wir nicht vergessen wir haben
die perspektive wirklich boris johnson
hat gesagt 21 juni dann alles wieder auf
weil es mit dem impfen dort schneller
geht glauben sie tatsächlich dass wir in
deutschland bis zum sommer jedem so sagt
es die kanzlerin und der
gesundheitsminister ein impfangebot
machen können und das ist dann auch
wirklich bergauf geht und alles wieder
aufgeht
ich glaube dass die chance da ist wenn
wir jetzt schon auf die impfstoffmenge
die insgesamt dann auch zur verfügung
stehen werden
und wenn wir es wirklich schaffen die
infrastruktur jetzt entsprechend
aufzubauen
da gibt es eine chance dass wir dann
auch im verlaufe des sommers tatsächlich
große teil der bevölkerung geimpft haben
und dann sind wir in einer situation in
der lage dann tatsächlich eben auch das
leben entsprechend wieder zu öffnen und
die zugänge wieder zu machen die chance
ist da und ich finde das sollten wir
viel stärker nach vorne bringen und dann
sofort zurück werz denken und sagen okay
was brauchst dafür und verein nehme auch
alle antworten die wir brauchen ja die
unternehmen mit an bord nehmen verbände
mit an bord nehmen und eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung zu bringen das machen
die amerikaner jetzt schon finde ich gut
sie haben das von angesprochen der
müsste schon bald mal wein hat eine
fabrik in den usa besucht die kanzlerin
anderen ministerpräsidenten müssten die
mal viel offensiver da vorgehen und auch
mal so eine ruckrede halten
kriegsproduktion all die dinge die nur
seine rolle spielen genau ob das ist
richtig weil das weiß ich nicht aber in
jedem fall wenn wir das gesehen hat auch
was die beiden auch verkündet hat als er
uns besucht das war vor zwei wochen hat
er die site in kalamazoo besucht hat
schon große worte gewählten hat gerade
das ist die größte logistische
herausforderung vor der die usa
gestanden und hier wurden wunder
verbracht er gesagt es ist ein wunder
der forschung dass überhaupt ein
impfstoff gibt ja innerhalb von weniger
als einem jahr und es ist ein wohl
jetzt der produktion dass wir diese
mengen produzieren also das hat die
dinge schon den wünschen sich ein besuch
der kanzlerin bei ihnen oder bei anderen
impfstoff herstellen also ich sag mal in
deutschland sicher bei antec die ja
sozusagen die die produktion die haben
da ist sie sicherlich jederzeit
willkommen bei uns natürlich auch
jederzeit willkommen ist auch schon
solche signale also das stärker nach
vollen zügen wir sind natürlich sehr
stark konzentriert auf die herausfahren
wir haben uns super lösung das ist auch
verständlich weil alle suchen danach das
ist richtig aber wir brauchen einen
größeren wurf also auch ein impuls und
mehr zutrauen
wir schaffen das wir kommen da zusammen
durch aber auch jetzt alle sozusagen
alle beteiligten an einem strang ziehen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren